hello and welcome to wild ride with
stevo
yeah a couple episodes back i said to
the
devoted people who listen all the way
through that we are pulling the trigger
on a wild ride
clips channel and by golly we did
so check that link in the description if
you want to just get a little taste of
an episode
you never know could kick ass also
this guy you know i gotta say man as
much of a fan of saturday night live as
i've been
over the years i didn't have never met
this guy i don't even know him
did never think that he would agree to
be on the podcast
but not only did he he was really candid
and open
and a lot of fun to talk to man fell in
love with this guy
so check it out ladies and gentlemen
keenan thompson yeah
what's up man what's going on i want you
to meet my co-host
scott randolph what a dude pleasure
what it does also up in the front of the
van we've got
paul briskey what's going on keenan how
are you
i'm good paul how's it going it's great
man it's an honor to talk to you
yeah my pleasure man thanks for having
me on this wild ass ride where are you
guys broadcasting from
we are in the hollywood hills which
gives me great anxiety man because my
house
is just in a big mountain of
kendall oh god you know
where are the fires at right now they're
all over they're like in uh
kind of close arcadia pasadena area
you got one by uh palmdale and then the
whole [ __ ]
the whole valley is just smoky from
washington to oregon to here
yeah i haven't seen the sky in like five
days
crazy i'm i'm surprised you guys aren't
all coughing
together yeah where are you are you in
new york
yeah i'm in new york now we're getting
ready to go back to the show and [ __ ] so
i just took my kova test
and we're about to get tested every day
yeah scott's been tested nine times
like eight or nine times come for a
record yeah yeah i've got my
six west which ones are you getting the
deep nasals
i've gotten it all dude i got the one
where you cough swab your mouth your
nose
your butt how was this how was the how
would the butt swap
pretty good
no it's good we just have people on the
on the show you know so
i would just feel guilty if i if i gave
it to somebody yeah yeah no doubt or
like if i go on a date
you know then like [ __ ] dude we just uh
we just made stevo condoms
right because we're in the merch game
and yeah
scott managed to fit his huge [ __ ] into
uh
for a test run yeah i had to do r d for
the product development phase of it
you got to make sure it fits every man
[Laughter]
yeah so dude
let's uh get into it man i can't even
believe uh what what what an honor it is
to have you on here man
it's uh man it's it's it's a it's the
pleasure is all mine
man i'm a big fan of you guys you know
we had johnny on the show years ago
and he was an awesome dude but i haven't
had the chance to meet the rest of you
guys i mean
i feel like i might have bumped into you
once maybe steve but
i can't really recall either way i'm a
giant fan so it's
it's a pleasure to be on here man cool
man well
[ __ ] yeah so are were you a child
star like how how young were you when
you
did the first the the first show and
that
was called all that yes i was like 15
when i first started on nickelodeon so i
don't know how much of a star
we were but we were like working kid
actors i don't know how many you were
stars dude i was a kid in the 90s you
guys were for sure
boy i mean how many times are people
like welcome to good burger like does
that get old after a while
i mean it's not my line you know what
i'm saying so i just i let it fly
and let people have their fun with it
you know what i'm saying but
for kale i'm sure it's probably starting
to get a little bit annoying
maybe you know he's been living with it
since we were 18. we shot that movie we
were 18
i'm 42 now you know what i'm saying so
he's been living with it for a while
yeah dude it's so crazy to think about
your career because you guys were
yeah like 15 18 doing these i mean you
were stars
to me but did you like uh
i don't know you didn't feel like a star
at the time did you just feel like oh
we're just doing kid stuff or
well yeah at the time it was just you
know on cable you know what i'm saying
so it's like whoever had it
had it basically so it took a while we
thought we were cool so we went out to
like the mall and stood around to see if
anybody would recognize this and [ __ ]
and like [ __ ] nothing happened but
you know it was like years later or
whatever you know like once it got into
like season three-ish i guess people
started really knowing about it but
you know we started out in orlando just
you know kind of entertaining those
orlando
universal studios audiences wow i mean
but that was nickelodeon right
yeah i mean nick loading the 90s like
that was huge because yeah
i think kanan's being humble yeah
i think there's a lot of modesty going
on here because that was at a time when
there wasn't any like internet really
right
you couldn't watch video on the internet
yeah like uh when jackass came out that
was only on cable
and [ __ ] jackass came out my life went
bananas
you know yeah but that's that's adult
humor you know what i'm saying it's
different when you're on a kid's network
so it was like amongst the kids for a
good while
in the beginning but yeah it blew up
like by the time it was like
late late 90s or whatever it was yeah
super popular
i think that it's impossible to become
famous without going through some kind
of
growing pains because all of a sudden
now you can
pretty much get away with whatever you
want you know like
i certainly you know
i think that it was important for me to
get the [ __ ] out
of uh of florida where i lived when
jackass came out
because all of a sudden it was like i
could i could get lots of chicks
you know like i could do like lots of
stuff and and uh
i remember like i had this this one
chick i hung out with all the time
and i really kind of burned her you know
it was like oh dude i'm
i'm doing my thing i might you know and
i was like man i'm starting to treat
people shitty
i got to get the [ __ ] out of here you
know i moved out to l.a
and uh and then it was a totally
different experience in la
where it's like now everybody's you know
this is where it's all going on
and people are just saying man like you
got a show now but it's gonna get
canceled you better hurry up man
it's gonna be it's gonna be over dude
and uh
everybody's being shitty together it's
all good
that's exactly right it's all good and
then with all the drugs and the alcohol
were you a kid did you were you partying
and stuff
ah partying i used to do that quite a
bit
but you know what i'm more into these
days sleeping
and if you're a fan of this podcast you
know
i love my bed and i particularly love
the mattress
on it because it comes from helix
sleep.com and
when you go there go to helixsleep.como
that's h-e-l-i-x
sleep.com stevo where you take a
very simple short quiz just a couple
minutes and they will tell you exactly
what's the best mattress for you
and by gosh do they get it right because
i
love getting in this comfortable bed i
always sleep better and feel better when
i wake up
and i want the same for you so by going
to helixsleep.como
picking out the mattress they are going
to give you up to 200
off of any mattress that you get and
with each mattress order you're going to
get two helix
pillows which are the most comfortable
pillows i have ever slept with
so what are you gonna do right now
you're gonna go to helix
sleep.com stevo you're gonna pick out a
mattress
and you're gonna thank me for it now
let's party
yeah i mean i hung out but i was never
like overly exposed to drugs like hard
drugs
necessarily so thank god i got to
squeeze past that kind of temptation but
you know
we had good times i used to go to the
club a lot and hang out and [ __ ] but
drinking was never really my thing
either so i never really got too wild
with that
i definitely had my you know one too
many nights or whatever
but you know nothing major he's like the
perfect role model for like a
nickelodeon act you know
right i mean that that's great like it
it never seemed like uh you always got
roles easily right i mean you had tv
shows and you did mighty ducks too and
you did
like yeah for a while yeah i mean
when i first started out i was lucky to
like go from job to job and then
i left nickelodeon and uh it was a
couple years of
you know hit and miss or you know a more
sporadic type you know job every six
months type of situation
and then i got on snl and that kind of
you know bridge that gap
basically so since then i've been you
know
taken seriously i guess for sure and now
you're a staple you're
like you're the longest running snl cast
member ever now that's so killer man
yeah i mean [ __ ] crazy man that is
crazy they used to talk about a curse
of saturday live with like you know
people getting so out of control
and uh you know we talked to kevin neal
and yeah
a couple weeks ago and and he's not
like is is the curse over did we beat
the curse are
people are people out of control still
yeah i mean it depends on the person you
know what i'm saying like i think it's
not necessarily the curse it's the
business you know and
there's a lot of people around this
business that if you're getting hot or
whatever
want to like you know be tiger's honors
or whatever and
contribute to the party in whatever way
they know how most of the time it's
negative
but nowadays the cast is very humble and
you know kind of like fans of the show
so we're not trying to like make waves
as far as
you know being out of control is
concerned you know what i'm saying like
we are all
fans of you know will ferrell's and
the jimmy fallons and the eddie murphys
and all those people you know what i'm
saying so
we kind of take it pretty seriously like
some people you know
might do a little bit of partying or
whatever getting out of control but
you know for the most part everybody's
like pretty focused on
making sure that the show continues to
you know live up to its name
basically it's going into [ __ ] season
46 this [ __ ] is crazy
and you said that you have a covid test
for the new season so does that mean
that the new season
is not gonna be like virtual on zoom and
[ __ ]
no we're going back into the studio
is there an audience we're trying to
make a swing at it we're going back into
the studio
um i'm not sure about the audience part
of it all but i'm i'm hearing rumors
about
you know maybe like a bubble audience or
something some kind of pre-tested
audience or testing on the way in or
some [ __ ] like that so
that still has to be figured out and you
know relayed to me whatever that answer
is but
somebody's going to need to start like
responding to what we're saying
otherwise that's just going to be a cold
experience
yeah yeah that's crazy yeah for god's
sakes man like all the late night talk
shows doing monologues with no audience
is kind of weird
yeah yeah it's kind of cool too when you
guys write a bit for snl
like do you write week of and then you
you perform it saturday
how long until you finalize the bit and
then gotta remember your lines for it
i mean well we use cue cards but um
we're constantly like looking for the
better joke all the way up until it's
you know broadcast basically until it's
live so
you know we're constantly rewriting and
stuff like that and we write
mainly on tuesday and table read it on
wednesday and then start rehearsals
so you know we have maybe
70 hours basically to get it as tight as
possible
something like that 70 hours how's that
different than like a three camera show
on nickelodeon or something is it harder
or easier
it's harder i would say it's way more
intense you know because it's your one
shot at it like
anything that's recorded you know you
can [ __ ] take your time and either
try to get it right or make your piece
with it you know what i'm saying like
snl is just like
okay that's that that's out there you
know what i mean i [ __ ] fell on my
face in that entire sketch but whatever
like there's no get backs so that part
of it makes me take it very seriously
too
yeah when people talk about snl they
talk about like how grueling it is how
much work it
is and it's sort of like oh my god i'm
so glad i got out of there but you've
been doing it for 15 years like what's
your do you have a secret for like
your longevity with it that you haven't
burnt out yet
well not to correct you but i'm going
into season 18. oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] so that's 18 years sid is crazy
um yes this is the start of 18 baby
excuse me then but no it's it's
it's all good i don't know i mean i deal
with the stress in it in a different
kind of way
you know what i'm saying and i i just
feel like
the people that leave the show they're
never as happy when they come back to
the show you know there's always that
i miss it here type of look in their
eyes and [ __ ] like that so
i started working in [ __ ] before i got
there so i know what it's like to go
back to
just being an actor for hire type [ __ ]
and i'm not in a hurry for that
man well um do we have uh
alec baldwin as trump is that just the
[ __ ] best
it i mean that dude's a right it scares
me because he gets such
uproarious you know applause or whatever
i'm like okay who exactly are they
clapping for you know
but i mean i hope he does it until
there's no reason to do it anymore
you know he just has i don't know i
think right now he has
you know a pretty solid take on it so
it's just been
really strong for the show and strong
for him too you know if he can just
stop fighting with people over parking
space
he just had his fifth kid too right yeah
the guy's a machine
shout out to his wife they're all under
like seven
i think five kids under seven that's
crazy yeah
i mean has saturday night live
i mean i guess it's always been a little
bit political but
in in recent years it's been like so
political is that
fair to say yeah it's very fair to say
it's been
you know a giant platform for opinion
you know what i'm saying so when it
comes to like election years
it's a big deal that's probably one of
the main reasons we're pushing to go
back into the studio this year
you know what i mean because it's an
election year and people go
to snl not necessarily to form opinions
but
definitely to kind of fine-tune what
their opinions are
and how it's matching up to you know
everybody else yeah i mean [ __ ] i love
it dude
i love all the political [ __ ] and i just
wonder it's sort of a rule of
like etiquette like don't bring up
politics or religion
and uh the cold open is it's politics
and religion yeah
i mean not really religion as much but
but but when you think of that rule
as like you know sort of
you would imagine that saturday night
live is kind of
alienating like the whole trump base
and how does that you know do you see
that in the ratings and it's like oh
[ __ ] it this is what we're gonna do
like uh because if you're a trump
supporter you can't watch saturday love
i guess right
now whichever way you happen to lean
politically
if you're a fan of the wild ride podcast
then
you know i really love this thing i wear
on my right wrist
again sometimes people say what are you
wearing two watches for
well one's a smart watch and the other
one
is my whoop band which is the
most top-notch fitness tracking device
out there by a mile i'll never
get a smart watch that can tell me as
much as my woop band does
it works with an app and it's a
membership service right you sign up for
the membership you get the band for free
and you use the app to find out
everything that is going on with your
body your sleep
your recovery your strain your
activities you
track your fitness okay since i got this
thing
i've never taken it off once and i don't
ever have to
because i carry the charger in my pocket
and it slides on right over the band
boom
charging all the time always telling me
what's going on
makes me healthier and i want it to make
you healthier too
so go to woop.com that's w-h-o
dot-com and use the promo code stevo you
get
15 off at checkout
do this for your own health
and to support this podcast but just do
it
get your whoop band sign up for the
membership
get the deal with the promo code stevo
and
sleep better recover faster train
smarter that's right okay so again 15
off at checkout at woop.com using the
promo code stevo
you're going to thank me for it now i
mean you can why i think i feel like we
hear more from trump supporters than
anybody so they're definitely watching
regardless you know what i'm saying
like show after show after show it's
like how could you say that you know i
mean it's like well if you weren't
watching you wouldn't know about it
but i mean as far as like
do we worry about who we're alienating i
don't think so only because
you know a lot of people i guess are you
know kind of liberal-ish
but at the same time we don't really
pick sides when we're writing
material you know what i'm saying we're
kind of just presenting what happened
basically
this year it's shipping from like seth's
show
or jimmy you know jimmy doesn't really
do much politics but seth is you know
very straightforward his opinion and
probably a lot of people's opinions at
that show
but you know we're more of a melting pot
situation so
right i think we try to just give equal
time we say we want to
we offer equal time to you know both
sides to come
and participate so yeah i think that uh
again i think that that that's exactly
right um
how much does the audience
get divided between television
viewership
and youtube viewership like
um i think it's pretty significant um
they're definitely making sure that
we're covered in both places you know
what i'm saying so
if it wasn't significant i don't think
they would go out of their way to make
sure that those youtube clips are up as
soon as possible or anything like that
like right
they might be up during the show you
know what i mean like as soon as
something airs
the clip might be available just
immediately if especially if it's making
like headlines or whatever so
right it's um it's definitely a new age
and
you know andy sandberg and those guys
like brought in a whole different you
know aspect to the show with the digital
shorts and [ __ ] like that so
it's one of those you know adjustable
type things that the show has been able
to kind of do
yeah it's definitely changed the
industry a lot and i wonder like it
new york is three hours ahead of la so
when it airs in new york i wonder if
in la we can watch the clips on youtube
before it even comes on tv
right and that's how it used to be it's
live across the nation now so
that's cool and you guys get like a
rerun at 11 30.
so you get two shows every night as
opposed to everybody else
but yeah nowadays when we go live it's
live across
[ __ ] crazy who's been your favorite
like snl legend to do a scene with
i mean recently it was murphy but before
he signed up it was sandler because you
know
both of those two are like the prodigal
sons you know what i mean they hadn't
been back to host and [ __ ] like that and
i'm a big giant fan of both of them so
it was um you know
an amazing experience to work with those
dudes what about
the celebrity is it host your host
yeah like who's been who's been the the
best
i mean the easiest ones are you know
ex-cast members of course you know i
mean just because
they're just so in the zone with it and
they pretty much do
the whole show themselves damn near you
know what i'm saying so
that's always nice but really whoever
comes to play
chappelle was [ __ ] dope you know what
i mean but tom hanks is probably one of
the like
famous like as far as like famous
people's concerns he's probably the king
you know as far as how cool he is and
how funny he can be
right and willing to just be silly like
killing his pumpkins is the craziest
[ __ ] ever
has keanu reeves done it i
don't know if he did it back in the day
like in the 90s or something [ __ ]
but he hasn't done it recently he he
should yeah that'd be a good one
yeah i mean he's the dude as far as like
being known for being a nice guy
like it's all he's the top of the top of
the mountain him and tom hanks man for
sure are there any
celebrity hosts that you're like sort of
star struck by
like or at this point is it kind of
they're probably star struck by you now
i get star struck by all of them you
know because usually if you're hosting
the show you're having a moment so
you've run across my tv
probably a few times i watch a lot of tv
so anybody i see sitting in that chair
i'm like holy [ __ ] man
there they are look at that that's
[ __ ] eddie murphy that's eddie
murphy's stomach look at that
that's great so uh
and apologies for not knowing this but
uh are you married get a girlfriend like
anything like that oh no no worries i'm
yeah i'm married i've been married eight
years
um and uh going on nine in a couple of
months and
we have two daughters two girls six and
two georgia and gianna
congratulations so yeah where'd you meet
your wife
here in new york hanging out with like
mutual friends
that aren't friends anymore that aren't
friends anymore
yeah just you know the hangout scene
some people grow up
some people continue to just stay in the
club so
once you you know couple up you have to
switch friends
yeah get your size domesticate yeah man
i
i got i got on that boat dude yeah
yeah man i mean where you got married
right i wear a ring as an engagement
ring
it's uh i'm not married yet but i think
that it's [ __ ] up
that women get engaged they should have
a ring on to indicate it
but the guy doesn't have to indicate
[ __ ] is that like
does that mean that it's assumed the guy
can just keep [ __ ] everybody
yeah i mean is this like some kind of
like archaic [ __ ] patriarchal
[ __ ] where like the guy has no
obligation
probably but you know you're you sound
like a stand-up guy so you would you
would never do that
you put the ring on the representation
did you wear an engagement did you wear
a ring before you're married
well she didn't buy me one
we got tattoos together though yeah
that's even cooler
yeah that's pretty cool hey so are have
you been in touch with goldberg
i mean i know you guys were friends john
i had yeah i haven't talked to sean in
like 20 years unfortunately you know
like probably 20 plus like wow i haven't
seen him since
that's kel we were like that's another
years ago no goldberg was the next guy
the mad guy jesus poor guy
he's a man's guy what do you want
he's looking much better he's struggling
through mutual friends i've been able to
like reach out but i haven't
talked to him personally yeah what a
heartbreaking story but it's good i mean
he's
i think he has like six months now which
is kind of going he's got a new set of
teeth
he's got he's got a hell of a before and
after photo
oh my god it's unbelievable that's like
this should be the biggest morning sign
ever you know what i'm saying like they
should strap that around all these glass
pipes they've been selling these tobacco
shops
yeah yeah for sure man i mean
has that ever happened to you before
because i feel like it happens the most
extreme to childhood stars you know
where
you don't hear from them out of control
yeah
um no i don't have many you know child
i've had you know
childhood friends like pass away from
various things and stuff like that but
for the most part you know everybody's
you know healthy whether they stay
you know the course of acting or not you
know everybody you know is pretty much
doing all right you know what i'm saying
like some people are [ __ ]
billionaires that one kid from the
mighty ducks that was
on the other team that was like the main
actor katie like a billionaire off of uh
bitcoin or some [ __ ] like like
cryptocurrency
crazy he was like the main like
uh i guess the enemy and the first one
or second one
in the first one a little blonde kid
yeah wow holy smokes and uh
yeah i was just my buddy sent me an
article on him like yesterday he was
like he's a [ __ ] like crypto
billionaire and i'm like that's insane
[ __ ] so you know there's there's there's
levels to this [ __ ]
yeah there is the the net worth thing
like uh you know you can look up
anybody's net worth
and it's like yeah i don't know who's
making those numbers up
exactly have you ever looked up yours
steve well dude this is
i i don't know dude i didn't know [ __ ]
about it right
and then uh and then a buddy of mine
tells me
he's like oh yeah uh tosh.0 on comedy
central
[ __ ] made a joke about you he's like
just
talking about celebrity net worth and he
was like oh they said
you know uh johnny knoxville i forget
what it was like
you know i said a hundred million
there's a band margera like you know
50 million and then steve 2.5
and i and at the time i was like
[ __ ] out they know that
i was so buttered but then i go on to
realize like uh
you know all this time later that it was
purely by accident that they got it
right i think because i don't think
anybody else has an accurate number out
there yeah how would they
no no way there's no way i looked up
mine my [ __ ] is out of control
only because like people started acting
different and then like somebody somehow
mentioned it like
sideways or something in conversation
and i was like what
are you talking about and then i look
that [ __ ] up that [ __ ] is like [ __ ]
no there's no way i'm like i don't know
where all that money is but it ain't
over here mad modest
but you know when you look back on it
you still got 2.5 million dollars you
know what i'm saying so
that's that's [ __ ] dope yeah a lot
better than
a lot of these people that are so
unemployed these days because of our
leadership and whatnot but we're not
talking politics
we're not talking politics yeah dude i
think
you're about to do a cold open right now
what's going on
live from new york yeah did was there a
learning curve
for you when you started making that
money were you like just spending [ __ ]
you're like [ __ ] i got to put some away
for taxes or did you have a good
team on your side oh yeah no i had a
hard lesson early
like you know my first big check i had a
bad accountant that ran away with my
[ __ ]
so i was you know struggling through my
fame
times which was a conundrum for a lot of
people that would actually see me out in
real life and just be like well why are
you driving like a toyota when you
should be like
doing whatever the [ __ ] and i was like
just give me my mcchicken sandwich
and uh but you know she got you know i
just stay diligent and keep working and
everything is all right now you know
what i'm saying so i you
i was able to stay humble by force thank
god actually
yeah it seems like it's a a problem
because you're really good with like on
top of paying your taxes steve like
was there an issue for you dude i have
babysitters man i don't [ __ ]
do anything like i got my uh but even
with me like you're so adamant like
you gotta [ __ ] pay your tax like and
and and we had shack on you don't want
to wind up like wesley snipes you don't
want that [ __ ] man yeah the situation
yeah if they just choose to turn their
attention on you and your [ __ ] is not
correct
you don't want that so yeah 100 percent
your [ __ ] taxes
you got it like you just have to take
whatever
you're making and just think of it as
half of that is mine
and half of that actually is yours
you make a quarter of what you actually
make you know
i think no matter what like uh you know
no matter how much you make just that
just be in that mindset
yeah half i just paid my quarterly taxes
today so i have a good feeling
that a boy that a boy yeah i've been
working with scott
scott and i've been working together for
uh just about seven years now
and uh yeah because i you know i was
always used to someone taking out
my taxes with a paycheck and then you
know now that uh now that i'm
responsible for it
seven years later seven years later now
that i'm pbs has
worked you know and i didn't know and so
like i spoke with shaq
shaq had issues in the beginning he
talked about it's like and it seems to
be a common problem where people just
don't know when they're starting making
bank and
you know shaq's like dude oh yeah my
first deal i got 20 million
it's like i [ __ ] went out and spent
20 million you know
right
[Laughter]
it makes total sense to me if you don't
know it's like i got 20 million like
what is there to talk what do you mean i
don't have
what you said i have you know what i'm
saying but that's why
you know schooling is important and i
don't know financial [ __ ] lessons
i think should be almost mandatory i
think they kind of are for
young players now but yeah you know it
should be mandatory for anybody going
from
zero to [ __ ] 20 million dollars you
know what i'm saying like
what wouldn't you buy like i would
[ __ ] buy everything
yeah [ __ ] yeah when you started making
like killing
killing it with money like what was the
first major purchase that you that you
that you bought and you're like [ __ ] i
don't know if i should
i'm gonna treat myself cars always
that's always a car
answer would you buy it it's like a
mercedes
is that in atlanta or in new york cause
you don't wanna [ __ ] drive in new
york do you
i drive in new york i love it i do i'm
coming from atlanta
that's why you know what i'm saying i'm
just used to getting in my car and
driving myself around
and i don't know that public
transportation is cool and convenient
but at the same time like i can just be
in my own zone
you know what i mean and yeah not be
bothered or whatever or
be worried about stepping in [ __ ] or
piss or whatever you know what i'm
saying so
yeah i like to drive driving in new york
i pictured
50 cent like driving like some crazy
car name for sure like a a g or tracy
morgan
tracy morgan's always lamborghini and
down the new york streets and [ __ ]
whenever he has a new deal
i mean it's crazy like uh the the rent
in new york you know so expensive but
then even the the parking
monthly outrageous it's outrageous the
whole the whole situation like
even if you have a monthly spot wherever
you get to you got to pull into another
garage you know what i mean so you're
just paying out the ass
everywhere unless you're really good at
reading the parking signs and finding a
street spot basically but
a lot of the times yeah new york makes
you pay out the ass
they really do so are you a new york guy
to the end now or you
do you have property all over are you
going to stay in new york for a while
i mean no we live in tampa as well so ah
my family's close you know in atlanta
and what not so that's a good spot for
us too
so if i if it was up to me i would
[ __ ] move to italy or some [ __ ] and
just be there
you know got to continue to work you
know i think atlanta's looking pretty
good man you like atlanta i think
atlanta is pretty
[ __ ] cool but it gets hot as [ __ ]
though right yeah it's hot in here it
never
gets it gets hot as turd [ __ ] there's a
nickelodeon right there
yeah but yeah but like same as tampa
though
tamara gets super sweaty so you you've
done
18 years of snl do you have a number in
mind that's like okay like
30 i'm definitely stopping you know like
right
it's 33 but no it's like i mean
i feel like at the moment the closest
one to me
is like 20. you know what i'm saying
since i'm so close to 20
it'd be nice to get there but we'll see
what happens basically
it'd be cool to like do it so long that
like nobody will be ever be able to
break your record you know
yeah i mean it's probably there at that
moment right now
who's the closest to you i mean colin
jones has been there
you know probably like 16 years he just
hasn't been on camera i guess as long
because he was a writer for a long time
so
i don't know as far as like who's right
i think daryl
is still right behind me at 14 years so
nice wow yeah do we do we have an actual
date for when uh the new season starts
october 3rd who's going to be playing
biden said it
that's a great question i don't know
yeah it's been
today's does a great one uh woody
harrelson did it a couple of times
last year um so
i don't know exactly who's gonna do it
but hopefully somebody
great that'll continue to do it as long
as we need them to
yeah yeah and hopefully you got a spot
for larry david playing bernie sanders
because that's all
oh dude is it not [ __ ] uncanny
they're related did you see that how
they're like that makes sense
they did a genetic test and somewhere
down the line bernie sanders and larry
david are related in some way they're
the same person
the exact same person dude he does he
does that [ __ ] without even trying it's
really his voice and he only does this
motion that's all that's his whole
impression
that's great dude so killer man well
[ __ ] man
i think uh we should let you go man i'm
so glad
that we got to talk to you dude what a
treat man man
likewise man i really love you guys i've
always loved and respected
you know anybody that was able to carve
out a lane super strong for themselves
just doing what they wanted with a bunch
of buddies
you know that's like one thing that i
loved about sandler you know i mean he
was always like working with his buddies
and [ __ ] so
it just looks like a dream come true i'm
glad that you're still rolling and doing
your thing and
i know keeping [ __ ] going bro you know
what i'm saying yeah i appreciate that
i appreciate that so much yeah so hey
best of luck hopefully uh
being back in the studio works out and
and there's no
[ __ ] [ __ ] hopefully you got
people there to laugh at the jokes
and uh yeah continued success man thank
you so much
thank you man i appreciate it my dear
street team meaning those of you
who watch all the way through to the end
of the podcast
and then kindly help me promote
the podcast by taking a screenshot from
anywhere in it
and posting it tagging my guest who was
absolutely fantastic i'd love for you
guys to let kanan know that you enjoyed
the podcast
and as i said at the very beginning we
finally did launch
an actual wild ride clips channel
which we made unlike
the schmuck who put up a wild ride clips
channel that i didn't make
and has a bunch of videos on there that
i am mortified anybody would think
came from me uh i don't even know if
that's still up but that guy
really rubbed me the wrong way any case
you guys are the best thank you so much
and uh
get ready for next week i don't even i
can't even tell you what a banger that's
gonna be
all right yeah dude